WE.
ARE SHORTER OF A QUORUM AND SO
SOON AS WE GET THE CHORUS.
AND SAY ONE TWO THREE FOUR FIVE
SIX WE HAVE A QUORUM ARIMINUM
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MEMBERS MURATSUCHI HERE BROUGHT
TO CHEER ACOSTA HERE ACOSTA HERE
CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN HERE FLORA.
LARA HERE LONG.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY HERE MELENDEZ.
REYES.
STONE. STONE HERE NOW RIGHT
BEFORE GOING FURTHER RELATE TO.
.
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE. MOVED
AND SECONDED.
SP FORWARD TEAM NINETY THREE
ITEM NUMBER THREE NSP FIFTEEN NO
TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR.
SEEING NO OBJECTIONS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
S. B. FOURTEEN NINETY THREE SB
PASS REFER TO WATER PARKS
WILDLIFE COMMITTEE. AND FIFTEEN
OR TO THE SIZE OF.
DO PASSED BOTH WITH CONCERT
RECOMMENDATION. MEMBERS ROUTE
SWITCHING AYE PRESTIGIO AYE
ACOSTA AYE CASA AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA I LIMON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S.
REYES.
STONE. SEWN AYE.
THURMOND RIGHT WELCOME CENTER
THINKERS YEARS I'D THIS IS S. B.
ADD TO SIX TWO I WANT TO START
UP BY THINKING OF. YOUR STAFF
MISTER CHAIR MISTER CHAPEL.
DID EXCELLENT WORK ON THIS BILL
I WILL BE ACCEPTING ALL AID TO
THE AMENDMENTS ARE SPECIFICALLY
REQUESTED IN THE ANALYSIS.
THREE YEARS AGO IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN I AUTHORED SP TWO FOUR
SIX WHICH HAD AN OVER ARCHING
GOAL OF ADDRESSING THE LACK OF A
COOPERATIVE COORDINATED APPROACH
THE CLIMATE ADAPTATION.
BETWEEN THE STATE OUR REGIONS
AND LOCALITIES LOOKED AT HER AND
OTHER.
LOCAL ENTITIES IN CALIFORNIA SO
WE DID THREE THINGS
IT CREATED THIS INTEGRATED.
CLIMATE ADAPTATION AND AYE
RESILIENCY PROGRAM I CARP WHICH
IS REFERENCED IN A. THE STAFF
REPORT WHICH IS DESIGNED TO
DEVELOP A COHESIVE AND
COORDINATED RESPONSE TO THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE ACROSS
THE STATE TO PROVIDE FOR THE
CREATION OF THE STATE CLIMATE
ADAPTATION CLEARINGHOUSE. AND
CONVENE THE TECHNICAL ADVISORY A
COUNCIL TO PARA PROVIDE
SCIENTIFIC AND TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE ON CLIMATE CLIMATE
ADAPTATION I TO THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING RESEARCH SO. THIS BILL
SP TWO SIX TWO BUILDS UPON AND
CODIFIES THE GOOD WORK AT THE A.
A OPR HAS BEEN DOING PURSUANT TO
I SP TWO FOUR SIX A BY ENSURING
THAT WE CONTINUE.
BEYOND THIS ADMINISTRATION INTO
THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE TOOK THAT
MAKE SOME ACHIEVEMENTS WE
FORMALIZE DEAD TECHNICAL
ADVISORY COMMITTEE AND WE CALLED
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCY. WE
GIVE THE CCAR THE RESPONSIBILITY
TO MAINTAIN THE CLIMATE
ADAPTATION CLEARING HOUSE WE
REQUIRE THE CC A ARE TO OVERSEE
THE AYE CARP.
AND WITH THAT I'D ASK FOR NUYS
BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
YES CHAIR MEMBERS READ OUT S. ON
BEHALF IT CAN INSULATE REGIONAL
OPEN SPACE DISTRICT IN THE LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORES IN SUPPORT
TODAY. A WIN THE STATE STARTED
THINKING ABOUT ADAPTATION MANY
YEARS AGO THERE WASN'T A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN OR CONFERENCE
OF LAW THAT WAS ESTABLISHED. BY
THE. GOVERNOR THROUGH EXECUTIVE
ORDER AND THE LEGISLATURE
THROUGH VARIOUS BILLS HAS TRIED
TO PUT THAT PROGRAM TOGETHER. WE
THINK THIS IS ANOTHER AT A
EXCELLENT ADDITION TO THAT BODY
OF WORK TO MAKE SURE THEY WERE
BREAKING DOWN SILOS IF THERE'S A
COMPREHENSIVE EFFORT TO HOW.
BOTH STATE AGENCIES ARE
COORDINATING BUT THEN HOW THOSE
AGENCIES ARE COORDINATING AT THE
LOOK GOVERNMENT LEVEL. A VERY
STRONG SUPPORT DAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT. CHAIR MEMBERS REBEKAH
PLEA ON BEHALF OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON WE ALSO HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE WHICH
WOULD HELP THE STATE WITH
CLIMATE RESILIENCY. AND ALSO
BETTER PROTECT OUR CRITICAL
UTILITY INFRASTRUCTURE THANK YOU
CAN'T.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURRS MARK SMITH
ON BEHALF OF THE ROYALS AND
FOOTHILLS CONSERVANCY IN
CALIFORNIA TROUT IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. CAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL LYNCH ON
BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS OF THE LA
RIVER IN THE ENDANGERED HABITAT
WE CAN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ALEX SLIMMER THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY OUT WHILE WE VERY
MUCH SUPPORT THE INTENT OF THE
BILL WE THINK BE FURTHER
STRENGTHENED AND SO WERE WORKING
AT THE AUTHOR ON SENTIMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MCLAUGHLIN SENIOR ME UP THE
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS
AND TRANSPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
CONCERNED MISTER CHAIR OF
JONATHAN PART FREE FROM CLIMATE
RESULT WAS NOT ABLE TO BE HERE
TODAY YOU ASKED ME TO. PASS ON A
SPORTS WELL ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER WITNESSES
EITHER A SUPPORTER OPPOSITION
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE MOTIONS BEEN MADE
AND SECONDED.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
S. B. TWO SIXTY TWO BY SENATOR
ACOSTA THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED. AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ROUTE SEARCHING AYE MURATSUCHI
AYE ACOSTA AYE AYE ACOSTA AYE
CHAU. CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA. FLORA AYE LOW
MOAN.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
THE LENDERS KNOW VARIOUS.
STONE.
STONE I.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSE
YOU.
SATTAR MINING IS ON ITS WAY.
WE HOPE.
OKAY
.
FOR SURE CENTER MONEY. WELCOME
SIR.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER TWO SP TEN
SEVENTY NINE.
SO UNDERMINE
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS. GOOD
AFTERNOON.
I LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENT SUGGESTING
COMMENT THREE OF THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS ADDING PRIVATE FOR
FOREST LANDOWNERS. TO THE BILL.
SENATE BILL TEN SEVENTY NINE
AUTHORIZES
THE DIRECTOR OF CAL FIRE TO
ALLOW ADVANCE PAYMENTS FOR THE
FORCED HEALTH GRANT IN FIRE
PREVENTION FUND. GRANT PROGRAMS
CALIFORNIA IS EXPERIENCING
LARGER MORE INTENSE WILD FIRES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
CAL FIRE HAS CHANGED ITS POLICY
TO REQUIRE NON PROFITS
SPECIAL DISTRICTS
AND LOCAL AGENCIES THAT RECEIVE
FOREST HEALTH AND FIRE
PREVENTION GRANTS TO BE
REIMBURSED.
BECAUSE REIMBURSEMENTS GENERALLY
TAKE BETWEEN SIXTY TO NINETY
DAYS A DELAYING AND FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP CAN BE CREATED.
S. B. TEN SEVENTY NINE IS TIMELY
AS CAO FIRES CURRENTLY
DISBURSING.
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN GRANT PROGRAM
FUNDS.
I HAVE WITH ME CAMBER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT WITH THE
PERMISSION OF THE CHAIR. I THINK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANKS HI MY NAME IS KAREN BURN
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
AND THE NINETY EIGHT OR CITIES
AROUND THE STATE.
SAID OF THE INTERSECTION
CONSERVATION AGRICULTURE DOING
LOCAL WORK ON STATEWIDE
MISSIONS.
AND WHERE I'VE REALLY EXCITED
THAT WE'RE HERE TALKING ABOUT
THIS ISSUE TODAY A WHEN I DO
TALK TO MY MEMBER DISTRICTS
AROUND THE STATE THIS IS ONE OF
THEIR NUMBER ONE CONCERNS IF NOT
THEIR NUMBER ONE CONCERN.
AND.
AS YOU KNOW I WILD FIRES A
CRITICAL RESOURCE CONCERN THAT
WE HAVE IN THE STATE AND THERE'S
A REALLY SIGNIFICANT LOCAL AND
ASPECT TO THIS THAT CAN ONLY BE
DONE THROUGH LOCAL GROUPS LIKE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS AND FIRE
SAFE COUNCILS AND OTHER FOLKS
WORKING AT THE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
AND SO WE FEEL LIKE IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR A LOT OF THIS WORK
TO REMAIN LOCAL HOWEVER WHEN WE
DO FACE AND. THE CHALLENGES OF
I'M HAVING TO IS AS. YOU
REFERENCE BEING ABLE TO AND.
A CASH FLOW THE STATE ON THESE
PROJECTS WE CAN SOMETIMES GO AS
MUCH AS I ONE TO TEN MILLION
DOLLARS I THAT WERE CASH FLOWING
FOR THE STATE. AND THAT PURSUIT
CREATES A REALLY SERIOUS
HARDSHIP.
FOR THE LOCAL CONSERVATION
DISTRICTS IN FOR THE OTHER FOLKS
THAT THEY TAKE ON THIS MONEY.
AND WE THINK ABOUT HOW MUCH THE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS DO WITH
HOW LITTLE MONEY THEY ACTUALLY
RECEIVE IT'S ALWAYS KIND OF
AMAZING TO ME. I YOU KNOW REALLY
GREAT EXAMPLE IS THAT WE
RECENTLY RECEIVED AT THE TAHOE
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT.
RECENTLY RECEIVED A FORTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR A SMALL.
AS STRATEGIC PLANNING GRANT AND
TURNED THAT INTO A MULTI MILLION
DOLLAR EASEMENTS IN WHICH
THEY'RE GONNA DO ALL THE
RESTORATION PROJECTS ON JUST
THAT FORTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS. SO WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
THE FACT THAT THEY'RE TYING UP.
YOU KNOW ONE TO TEN MILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF THEIR ASSETS
WHAT THAT REALLY MEANS IS THAT.
THE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
AREN'T ABLE TO DO THE IMPORTANT
WORK THAT THEY'RE CHARGED WITH
DOING NUMBER ONE. NUMBER TWO IF
THEY DO DO THAT WORK THEY
OFTENTIMES HAVE TO COME UP WITH
CREATIVE MEANS OF PAYING FOR IT
WHICH MIGHT MEANS THAT YOU KNOW
MAYBE THEY'RE NOT PAYING THE
CONTRACTORS IN A TIMELY WAY
WHICH THAT HURTS LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
AND LASTLY THERE ONLY OTHER
OPTION IS REALLY TO TAKE ON AND
LOANS WHICH THEN RUN THEM
ANOTHER INTEREST RATE THAT GOES
ON TOP OF THAT. AND WHEN THEY'RE
ONLY BEING PAID SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN TWO PERCENT AND FIFTEEN
PERCENT OF OVERHEAD YOU OUT OF
THREE FOUR FIVE PERCENT LOAN ON
TO THAT AND IT MAKES IT ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THEM TO GET THE
WORK DONE. SO THIS ISSUE IS SO
CRITICAL TO LOCAL CONSERVATION
AND SO CRITICAL TO THE WORK THAT
WE ALL DO LOCALLY THAT WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS BILL COMING
FORWARD. RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THIS BILL DOES ENJOY A
SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION FROM BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE.
CHAIR MEMBERS READ OUT ASSEMBLY
HAPPENED IT PENINSULA REGIONAL
OPEN SPACE DISTRICT IT IMPORTANT
BILL BOTH FOR OUR ORGANIZATIONS
AT OUR LOCAL PARTNERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN OTHER MEMBERS POLY
ORDER SHUDDERING INTO IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL IS WHEN I THINK ALL
THE MEMBERS WITH ALL. THAT FIRE
RELATED BILLS THIS YEAR REALLY
APPRECIATED THINK YOU'RE CHEN
AYE VOTE.
HI TASHA NEWMAN ON BEHALF OF
SAVE THE REDWOODS LEAGUE. AT THE
BIG SUR LAND TRUST AND THE
VIOLENCE CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT.
STERN MEMBERS HOW LOANS AS PART
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TOTAL ALLIANCE PENINSULA OPEN
SPACE STRESS SANTA CLARA VALLEY
OPEN SPACE AUTHORITY. AND CINEMA
COUNTY AGRICULTURAL PRESERVATION
AND OPEN SPACES SHACKLED SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURSE IN SUPPORT.
AND JENNIFER COMPUTER THOUGH ON
BEHALF OF THE MONTEREY COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING NO IN COMING FORWARD AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE MOTIONS BEEN MADE
AND SECONDED.
CENTER MONNING I DIDN'T GIVE
CENTER Y. CASKET OPPORTUNITY
CLOSE BUT.
YOU LIKE CLOSE.
I JUST APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ADAM SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
I AM TO S. B. TEN SEVENTY BY
SENATOR MONNING THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS THROUGHOUT SEARCHLIGHT
ROUTES HOOCHIE AYE ACOSTA AYE
FASA AYE CHAU. CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA FLORA AYE AND
THE MONIQUE. LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S LINDA'S
AYE RAYOS AYE.
VARIOUS AYE STONE. SONAE TEN
ZERO TENS YEARS BILLS OUT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THINK YOU
MEMBERS.
S. MEETINGS CHART. ONE THE CALL
NO I'M SORRY.
CAN I UNDER TURN.
YES.
TAKEN OUT WE WILL LIKE OF AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO ADD ON TO. THE VOTES.
OKAY SO ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
SHALL I.
MELENDEZ MULLIN DESIROUS.
YES I TEN ZERO.
AND ON ITEM TO.
S. FIFTY.
I'M SORRY.
ON ITEM ONE S. B. TWO SIXTY TWO.
ABSENT MEMBER RAYOS.
VARIOUS AYE.
NINE ONE.
OKAY.
NOW RETURNED